noticed by most people was the land
reform provision
in the democrats most recent coronavirus
relief bill it allocated
billions to so-called farmers of color
at the same time that bill
denies money to farmers who have the
wrong skin color that is
by definition racism it's clearly
illegal under the law in the civil
rights act
now several farmers are suing over it as
they should but msnbc doesn't like that
msnbc just ran a segment accusing those
farmers of being white supremacists
and really you know his group america
first legal
a a more accurate name for it would be
white men
first legal because it really is about
attacking any
efforts to make society more equitable
for marginalized communities
and and so far all it is is doing and
trying to do is to create hysteria
um around efforts to to make society
a more livable place for
uh brown and black communities for for
women for you know
for for not for anyone who's not a white
man
adam faust is not the picture of
privilege he runs a farm he's lost both
his feet
he's one of the farmers suing over this
racist law he joins us tonight with his
attorney rick essenberg
admin rick thanks both for coming on
tonight um
adam just summarize for us why you're
filing this suit
if you would oh well
basically just because race says i mean
racism against anybody is wrong and yeah
we can't have a government that's
being picking and choosing who they're
gonna give
any program to based solely on the
color of their skin so you grew up in
this country i can tell by your accent
weren't you taught all along the way
that that was contrary to the
constitution to federal law to martin
luther king's vision
of america are you surprised by this
extremely i mean like you said
everything that we've all learned
growing up is
racism was wrong and now all of a sudden
the federal government seems to think
that
racism is acceptable in certain ways and
yeah should never be accessible
acceptable
no it shouldn't and if you complain
about it you're a white supremacist
uh so rick how can this law be legal i
don't remember anyone pointing that out
when it passed but i thought there were
plenty of federal laws that banned
this kind of discrimination no it can't
be our courts have made clear for a
number of years tucker that
the right to be free of racial
discrimination is an individual right
that we
all have it's not a group right there is
no such thing as benign discrimination
there's no such thing as a little makeup
discrimination to even things out
you know when the msnbc commentator
talks about equity
i mean we are all for laws that prohibit
discrimination
but those laws have to apply across the
board to people like adam
as well as to black and hispanic farmers
so if the next administration said you
know we're picking a different racial
group and we're just going to send the
money because of how they were born
i mean do you think that would make it
through the courts would that
would that go unnoticed no it
and it wouldn't i mean look we we fought
a a civil war
we had a lengthy civil rights movement
to acknowledge the principle
it was in our founding documents that we
are all to be treated as
individuals and this uh really
disturbing move that we have now towards
equity
instead of equality of opportunity will
not end well it will
lead as i think you're pointing out to a
war against all against all
uh where we all are looking for our
racial spoils and
and that's simply not what america is
about and i'm so
glad that adam is willing to stand up
and
and fight this now before before it
becomes
far more acceptable than it is this is
immoral and it is unconstitutional and
illegal
well it's totally immoral adam really
quick are you surprised that you're
being attacked as a bad
person for standing up against racism
yeah it does surprise me since what
we're doing is
anti-racist i mean we're fighting racism
for everybody in the country not just
one group and yet some people seem to
think that being
anti-racist is now racist
yeah you don't seem very privileged to
me i i'm rooting for you here and for
the entire country
people of all colors too this is a
principle that we have to preserve
obviously adam and rick i appreciate you
coming on tonight thank you
thank you thank you hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else